sie haben überlebt erst die angriffe auf
ihr dorf dann die flucht vor syriens
machthaber assad und jetzt einen
drohnenangriff auf offener landstraße
der einem al qaida kämpfer galt die
familie fuhr im auto dahinter zu den
großeltern die casinos eine einfache
bauernfamilie sie sind das was die armee
einen kollateralschaden nennt die kinder
saßen auf dem rücksitz
meine ganze familie wurde verletzt mein
sohn und ich wir sind zu schwer
getroffen und wir haben kein auto mehr
uns ist nichts geblieben
mutter fatima müsste wieder ins
krankenhaus doch sie hat panische angst
vor der fahrt aber die entzündung
bekommen sie hier nicht in den griff
ich weiß nicht wie ich meine gefühle
beschreiben soll ich sehe den schmerz
meiner frau mein sohn meine töchter
mahmud beine und der kopf ich habe seit
vier tagen nichts mehr gegessen
der ort al yami hier leben die
großeltern die gegend ist auch ein
rückzugsgebiet für al qaida kämpfer am
dritten dezember ist die familie auf dem
heimweg fröhlich film die kinder der
motorradfahrer im blauen anorak ist das
ziel des drohnenangriffs gleich wird am
anderen ende der welt ein us-soldat den
knopf drücken es ist der moment in dem
sich vater ahmed entschließt zu
überholen
[Musik]
es gleicht einem wunder dass der
zehnjährige mahmud überlebt er wurde im
35 kilometer entfernten idlib
notoperiert danach lag er drei tage lang
im koma ihm fehlt ein teil des
schädelknochens
tage später kehrt vater ahmad an die
abschussstelle
zurückfindet teile seines autos
die haben saft getrunken wir waren
glücklich auf dem weg nach hause die
kinder hatten spaß
mit einem schlag verwandelte sich dieses
familienglück in ein blutbad schreie wir
haben alle geschrieben ich tat was ich
konnte dann kam rettung daran erinnere
ich mich dass da habe ich getrunken
das ende eines familienausflugs mehr als
300 drohnen einsätze hat die globale
allianz gegen terror im norden syrien
dieses jahr geflogen
dieser wurde gefilmt
[Musik]